we start today with a major story
the wife of supreme court justice
clarence thomas jenny thomas
we now know
was way more involved in the lead up to
and supporting the attempts to overthrow
the correct
accurate real winner of the 2020
presidential election she was involved
in emails with donald trump's attorneys
she was involved in emails with arizona
lawmakers who were trying to figure out
a way remember this
alternate slate of electors that they
wanted to send to washington dc
ginny thomas was extremely involved and
we now know it now we suspected this for
months because of little bits of data
and evidence here and there
but now
thanks to the january 6th committee the
degree to which ginny thomas was
involved and we must wonder
what about clarence thomas i mean is it
really plausible that he has no idea
what she's up to and not at all
supportive of what she's up to it starts
to become hard to believe so let's go to
the primary report about this from the
washington post
ginny thomas corresponded with john
eastman sources in the january 6th house
investigation say
the house committee investigating the
january 6 attacks has obtained email
correspondence between jenny thomas the
wife of clarence thomas and lawyer john
eastman who played a key role in efforts
to pressure vice president pence to
block the certification of joe biden's
victory this is according to three
people involved in the investigation
remember eastman's the guy
who wrote the memo
telling mike pence uh or rather wrote
the memo explaining how mike pence could
reject the election results and send it
back to the states as they love to say
none of this is true none of this is
real none of this is based on real in
reality but that's who john eastman is
and jenny thomas was corresponding
directly with him
the article goes on to say the emails
show that thomas's effort to overturn
the election were more extensive than
previously known
the three declined to provide details
and spoke on the condition of anonymity
the committee staffers and members are
now discussing whether to spend time
during the public hearings exploring
jenny thomas's role in trying to
overturn the outcome of the 2020
election the washington post previously
reported the committee had not sought an
interview with thomas and was leaning
against pursuing her cooperation the two
people said the emails were among
documents obtained and reviewed recently
last week a federal judge ordered
eastman to turn more than a hundred
documents over to the committee eastman
was trying to block those
thomas also sent messages to president
trump's white house chief of staff mark
meadows that this is ginny thomas was in
touch with eastman
mark meadows and to arizona lawmakers
pressing them to help overturn the
election
thomas has maintained she and her
husband operate in separate professional
lanes
her activities as a conservative
political activist have long
distinguished her from other spouses of
supreme court justices
any new revelations about her actions
after the 2020 election are likely to
further intensify questions about
whether thomas clarence thomas should
recuse himself from cases related to the
election and attempt to subvert it
this is a major major deal one other
piece of this that i wanted to mention
to you
um
about the arizona
element
um
she was in touch with 27 ah here we go
in the weeks after the 2020 election
jenny thomas repeatedly pressed mark
meadows to overturn the outcome as if he
can do it she told meadows in a text she
was disgusted with pence who didn't
block the certification of biden's
victory she said we are living through
what feels like the end of america and
then during the same period she was
pressing republican lawmakers in arizona
to help keep trump in office by setting
aside biden's popular vote win and
choosing their own electors which is
completely and absolutely bonkers so
this is truly madness
now
there are reports that liz cheney who's
on the january 6 committee
has been hesitant or resisting really
pulling in jenny thomas into part of the
investigation
but these are absolutely questions that
americans deserve to see answered
publicly particularly particularly if
elements of the january 6 riots may come
before the supreme court
um i'm not sure about you know this it
would be a waste of time to bring ginny
thomas in well i don't know about that
but the involvement of jenny thomas
needs to be looked at completely and it
is it it's damning that clarence thomas
did not recuse himself on the january 6
document production case that made its
way to the supreme court think about it
on the one hand his wife is out there
involved in trying to make certain
things happen on january 6th
and also is mentioned in all sorts of
the documents that are at issue that so
his wife is relate she is a party to
many of these documents and
communications
and he then gets to decide whether it's
appropriate or not whether it's legally
justified or not for documents to be
released and turned over that's
outrageous it's completely outrageous
and just think for a second
imagine that it was sonia sotomayor's
husband
who was in a similar situation who had
been texting and emailing and pushing
for the election to be given to someone
other than the person who actually won
do you think republicans would be silent
no
it would be 24 7 on fox news
the hunter biden laptop story which is
almost nothing look at how much coverage
that received imagine if uh you know a
family member of elena kagan was it it's
outrageous and um this has to be
explored and there are so many
extremists listen they're not just close
to the government they're in government
as well but even on the periphery of
government and on the periphery of power
they are everywhere and it is very
difficult to believe here we're making a
judgment call i don't know that much
about uh ginny and clarence thomas's
relationship but do we really believe
that jenny thomas is this involved she's
contacting lawmakers she's in touch with
the president's chief of staff
uh she's in touch with john eastman and
clarence thomas knows nothing has no
opinion and is completely neutral about
what she's doing right like imagine that
hey clarence i'm in touch with eastman
i'm in touch with meadows i'm trying to
keep trump in power i'm trying to push
for a different slate of electors to be
sent from arizona and clarence thomas
goes oh that's really interesting i have
no opinion one way or the other about
what you're doing give me a break guys
and i know there are some weird
relationships in washington dc but it is
very difficult to imagine that that's
the case now
at this point
what i would
i mean you know we talk about taking the
high road taking the low road democrats
should do what republicans would do if
the situation was reversed
go to them and go to thomas and say
listen clarence thomas needs to go
clarence thomas should resign
we'll have joe biden pick a right
leaning justice so it won't change the
balance of the court and then ram
through a progressive in the middle of
the night this is what this is what
republicans would do okay
and this is what democrats should do if
you disagree with me let me know as many
of you know i'm a busy person i don't
always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high-quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning it when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day it supports gut health and
i'm getting everything that i need and
i'm looking for athletic greens is
giving my audience a free one-year
supply of vitamin d plus five free
travel packs when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below